تعال إلى أيسلندا من أجل الروعة
والدليل الواضح على فعالية
لقاحات covid19 ، كم عدد الأشخاص الذين
لقوا حتفهم في هذا البلد خلال هذه الموجة
من الخير الذي لا يطمع في
أي شيء
، وهو
كبير علماء الأوبئة في آيسلندا ، وأعتقد أن
التطعيم المنتشر في آيسلندا
له  بالتأكيد منعوا
عواقب وخيمة أه للعدوى أشعر
بالامتنان وأعتقد أنها أه
شهادة
لهذا السكان الدكتور بول ماريا هو الرئيس
التنفيذي لأكبر مستشفى في أيسلندا
لانس إيطاليا الجامعة الوطنية
وهو يقول سيناريو كابوس خلال هذا
الرابع و  تم تجنب أسوأ موجة من
الكوفيد بسبب زملائه في آيسلندا
إذا لم يكن للتطعيمات
في سكاننا ، أعتقد أنه كان من الممكن أن
يكون كارثيًا يقول مسؤولو الصحة أنه
لم يمت أحد من الطمع في الدولة الصغيرة
منذ 30 مايو مات قبل ذلك
تقريبًا  كل ذلك قبل أن
يتوفر اللقاح وكيف يتم تلقيح هذه الأمة
الآن إذا نظرت إلى الفئة العمرية  16
عامًا فما فوق ، فهو أعلى بقليل من 90 في
المائة
إذا كنت تأخذ من
سن 12 وما فوق ،
فهذه النسبة 84 نسبة مئوية فائقة ، مما يجعل العثور على الأشخاص
في الولايات المتحدة الذين لم يحصلوا على
اللقاح أمرًا سهلاً
هنا ، ليس بهذه السهولة ، هل حصلت على
اللقاحات ، نعم بالطبع نعم بالطبع ، لماذا
هل تقولين بالطبع فقط لأنه
مثل واجبنا المدني أن يتم التطعيم ،
إنه واجب كبير ، هل لديك
أصدقاء لم يتم تطعيمهم؟
عدد التطعيمات
يعني أيضًا عددًا أقل من المرضى على الرغم من
زيادة الإصابات
في العام الماضي قبل أن تتوفر لقاحات الغلاف
للجمهور الأيسلندي ،
كانوا عادةً ما بين 65 و 75
مريضًا مشمولًا في هذا المستشفى
في هذا اليوم ، وهناك 18 مريضًا مريضًا ،
بعضهم مصاب بمرض شديد ،
ثلاثة منهم  هم في قسم
العناية المركزة خلف هذا الشريط الأسود والأصفر ،
لكن أعداد المرضى استمرت في الانخفاض ،
لقد كان جنونًا تمامًا العام الماضي
ولكنه أكثر هدوءًا عند  في اللحظة التي يوجد فيها
عدد أقل من المرضى ويتعافون بشكل أسرع
مما كانوا عليه في الموجة الأولى ، لا
سيما أن وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية أصدرت
أخطر تحذير مرغوب فيه في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر قائلة إن عدم السفر إلى
زيادة آيسلندا المرغوبة أمر حقيقي ولكن
هذا هو الإحساس  التفاؤل أعتقد
أننا نوعًا ما كدليل على هذا
المبدأ القائل بأن التطعيم
يعمل ، عجائب
غاري توكمان CNN ريكيافيك أيسلندا